est ce que vous êtes en mesure de le
dire il ya eu combien commotion
cérébrale au sein des équipes membres de
football québec
l'année dernière par exemple ça se fait
parce que j'ai peur à saint malo
renseignements serein pour madame et
qu'est ce que je ferais avec ça mais
vous réaliseriez qui est un problème
important
si j'avais les renseignements je relise
rec un probleme surement un portable
peut-être pas si vous disais lequel vite
10 commotion cérébrale paris kate
sportive par annie est ce que vous
seriez surpris un wii sera surpris si la
rue c'est le cas dans les équipes qu'on
a suivi entre 5 et 10 commotion
cérébrale dans une équipe dans une année
aussi
alors c'est comment dire je ne sais pas
autant mieux que vous soyez là ça veut
dire que l'information sera cgppa
règlement sécurité est inscrit qu'à
chaque fois que l'incident sur un
terrain doivent fait l'objet d'une
visite chez le médecin
l'équipe doit vous aimera par écrit dans
l'étrange l'ours est un bel exemple de
ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure on peut
faire des règlements mettant d'échouer
mais dans la pratique ça ne se fait pas
vous avez reçu conviendra par
d'événements de la part des équipes
c'est à dire on est deux dans cette
fédération si on est inondé de champmol
prend bien on voit deux personnes à
temps plein dans toute la fédération